[Musik]
jungs spaß die hin und was wünscht dr
ja ich werde immer ein soft liebe
schweiz
noch wenn sie mit einfach die liebe hält
uns zusammen und treibt uns an
wenn ich sie anschaue sehe ich gucke
lieber
zurück das dank
[Musik]
nichts wäre und ich den stecker
ziehen
[Musik]
zunächst ruhig
obwohl es mich freuen
[Musik]
sv
oh
isny
da
[Musik]
nein
geschichte angefangen und der schweizer
peter eine familie gründet mit
aber vor zwei jahren tieres lieber
komplett abgestellt und noch mal ganz
neu anfangen und swatch in accra
[Musik]
familie schon stark warnt vor abzocke
charaktere die straßen gibt es
kultur zu
recht spontan sonst sehen
hallo
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und hund
[Musik]
die beta ist gerade im ruf mit einer
bekannte kunststoff ghana mit mattem rot
im
[Musik]
herzstück
[Gelächter]
sind
[Musik]
hänge und hotels in ihr machte frank der
wechsel von badezimmer
du geschätzt
hotelchefin
und wie verlaufen war
ja wie ich das
zu tun das ist auch gut
so
oder auch mit meiner familie am telefon
zum thema wie das lachen ist gesicht
saubere
als musiklehrer fünfte
ein bruder hat mir auch 1 gebracht
gebracht jetzt dass du dein bruder und
wie man
sieht im sumo 2010 familien ehrensberger
sekunde also es gibt kein tri nicht
zwischen privatleben und schaffe
der bt t shirts ghana studiert als
musiker einst in die afrikanische
trommler natur wenige tage vor der
rückreise zwei anderem ausgang mafia
keine
die vogue ist aber klar die swisscom
[Musik]
ihre familie hansen kanton aargau
gründet vor 15 jahren leben oft weltruhm
[Musik]
bei dieburg sind im dorf wie
ich bin und
kataster
schuhregal mir vor mir überfordert sich
jetzt für
kataloge zu blöd aber dass im kanton
aargau erreichen scania carlo nico
du irgendein fahrer ist es den schulen
wo mama
wenn ich bin monaco
und jetzt ist
[Musik]
das video ist der schweizer armee
spricht du gerne
[Musik]
vor der heimat von vorteil mit vor ihrer
mutter das ist ein großer schritt für
die beiden worte
[Musik]
was
ist
das überhaupt für mich empfindet
empfinde
sie ist meine seelenverwandte
sie hat mir wieder gezeigt was liebe ist
[Musik]
2009 hat die liebesgeschichte aqua für
dpa die ehemalige chefin von herrn
autobahn raus stellt der sprung über den
großen teich gewagt von langenthal auf
montana eine 50 sie
foto jw geht unter jay und ihre
außergewöhnliche liebesgeschichte hin
und weg kennen gelernt jetzt treffen sie
wieder ihre geschichte nimmt er
unerwartet die wände
oder da
und jetzt aussieht 23 monaten versucht
zu setzen was es ist und er steht mit
dem sid es kann ganz spezielle musik von
tumoren und
die operiert worden
[Musik]
keine einzige
online plattform bei digitec sie mit der
horror des krieges eine neue welt die
tochter
des native american und kurzem stand
wurden acorda wurde rocky mountains lab
british fasziniert von ihrer ganz
anderen kultur
die zukunft von
groß und das zeichen gegenseitiger
verbundenheit
[Musik]
ein wohncontainer scheer ist
heinz resch mit ihren schweiz gereist
und die beiden töchter aus erster ehe
prof
die schweiz müsse trocken und vermisst
sie jeden tag
hallo sind zwar
china hält brigitte und dj aktiv griffen
die entscheidung treffe sie wenn die
schweiz ziegler zum täter der recht vor
ihrem leben verbringen
[Musik]
die blumenmotive diese nachsorge dass
sie acht sein hinter anni hier könnt ihr
am anfang
[Musik]
sei wie verstärkt hat brustkrebs
erkrankung vor dem rat von rio mit
gesundheitlich wieder gut aber sie
realisiert dass ihre nummer ewig bleiben
jetzt will sie zwei crews reise zum
alles vorbereitet
dass ein zuvor seine krankheit zu planen
humor hilft der eu für lande zieht und
dort unterstützung von der familie
degussa und dante von jay helfen
der umzug segway ein richtiger schritt
es kommt auf die innere einstellung an
[Musik]
er wird es schaffen
er ist so weit
kannst du sie starten
lassen wir sie kurz laufen
er hat mir eine sprachnachricht
geschickt
alles gut bei euch läuft
der tank ist leer und mein motorrad ist
im transport modus wir haben es
geschafft
seine tante gibt acht dass er ist und
sich sorge trägt
ich werde niemals der ganzen stadt
suppen mitbringen aber
nichts scharfes
[Musik]
kona bedeutete sprach von agoda.de
freundlich
mit ihm
[Musik]
vielleicht tröstet raum über der
schwierige abschied hinweg
ein lebensabschnitt gott sein
[Musik]
mit irgendwie mit großeltern
in ghana
jahrhundert sagt nein das wird sicher
kein hund
[Musik]
der familie ehrensberger geht's unter
der woche früher
jungs
der hofstaat
da
die nächste gang getriebe hände
zu legen
sagt sie auch kurz und
[Musik]
verpflegung steht mein geschmack duftige
förderschule
königreiches ca
ja er hat damit
[Gelächter]
nach konter gar nicht geschlafen
vor
10 uniform dazu so weißen brautschuhe
das kind wenn nur der krawatte knopf
nicht
[Musik]
wenig gemacht
die beiden uhr beginnt eine privatschule
der unterricht in englisch ich würde
zehnjährigen recht jung stelle ich sie
da sind wir daher
wahrscheinlich im norden nigers
kein schock und der patch ist er mit
weil er gesund ist
[Musik]
ein fahrer bringt level ghana sind
öffentliche verkehrsmittel und sie
fahren im restlos wenn es voll besetzt
sind
für deren gibt's ein schulbus bis zur
haltestelle muss das stück gelaufen
jetzt jeden morgen nationalhymne
[Musik]
die temperaturen bald aerofreeze grad
die gibt sind alle frühauf dabei
[Musik]
[Applaus]
der unterricht dauert bis am nachmittag
am halbe 4
als sie auf mich zukam dachte ich oh ja
schon auf der heimfahrt sagte ich zu ihr
ich werde dich heiraten sie glaubte mir
nicht und sagte was
ich versuchte sie zu küssen aber sie
sich zurück was läuft das ist zu früh
[Musik]
auch brigitte toko nassim früher
unterwegs
mit wird dj nach seiner operation im
spital and low und der termin und
neuronen
heruntergeholt
das chaos
naja
ich komisch ausdrucken
und jetzt gehts umgekehrt sie das forum
inhalte mit warmer tee
[Musik]
beim prix geht die schweiz vor ruß reist
sind sie und dj 42 minute trend aber
der plan geht nur auf wenn er sich gut
erholt und kalk komplikationen hätte
sich so unberechenbar
darf gar nicht
positiv dank des kleines loch in das von
dante charlene bringt dj aus dem spital
[Musik]
er muss sich hier neben er hat starke
schmerzen
hatte er medikamente gegen die schmerzen
ich bin gleich das sehr gut danke
das ist typisch für ihn ja ich kann mich
nicht bücken
ja eine besondere erfahrung
jason hughes building als spirituelle
führer hilft dem ruf vertrauen dass
alles gut kommt
es liegt nicht in unseren händen
spirituell sage ich mir es ist passiert
und ich versuche damit klar zu kommen
meine großeltern unterstützen mich und
helfen mir
der schöpfer mutter erde und vater
himmel sie sind alle da und begleiten
mich
darum mache ich mir nicht so viele
sorgen ich weiß predigt und viele andere
beten für mich
ich habe etwas für dich fencheltee
wir lieben ihn den babys in der schweiz
gegen bauchschmerzen
du bist mein großes baby
stets besser
ich sollte etwas essen
bei mami und papi
er passt gar nicht mehr unter dem schuh
ja du wirst zu groß
[Gelächter]
sondern
auch
große bedeutung der kultur für
die krieger waren sie ein zeichen der
furchtlosigkeit im kampf versuchte man
sie an den haaren zu packen aber das war
uns egal wir waren immer noch stärker
als sie
und das ist die job für die frau im tor
mache
für sorg das ist liebe
will ist noomi wenn er älter und
abhängige wird von 1
mein kuss ich bin noch nicht fertig
dann will ich zwei
so ist es gut
[Musik]
das muss ich sowieso lernen
was ich an dir nicht mag ist es gibt
nichts was du an mir nicht mag manchmal
bist du ziemlich stur zu
mindestens 80 prozent ist mein weg der
beste
mindestens 80% ich jetzt nicht streiten
wir sind beide etwas stur das ist wahr
[Musik]
venice golden so heißt das quartier in
vichy
statisch 105 kilometer von shanghai
erweckt
matthias hat vier big er schafft das
leitende qualitätsmanagern schweizer
firma
du bist schon da so früh
es hatte nur wenig verkehr
mir geht's gut und hier mir auch
jonathan ist vielleicht etwas einsam
sieht des baumes sind sharon und
matthias ältere mit jonathan ist der
neue mittelpunkt vor ihrem leib
es ist prima bin ich früher nach hause
kommt wir sehen uns den ganzen tag nicht
die nächte bin ich bei job finden
wir brauchen auch unsere partei
in krina stück speziell im umfeld der
firma wenig somit andere junge familie
fact that lets zum teil über das sieht
auch in der bgh
aber
dass zum beispiel im winter wechseln
oder massiert das teilte jobs für die
frauen
nie habe ich einen chinesischen man
windeln wechseln sehen
gib mir die windel
[Musik]
der matthias macht teig für dumpings
gefüllte teigtasche familie ist meistens
chinesisch alles selber gemacht und
immer mehrere griff er husak stellt die
unterstützt sharon und ihre mutter
wie groß muss er sein
matthias ist fast ein profi
du kannst das besser als meine mutter
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
man macht es mir nie
rampling smint uhr zugemacht werden wenn
sie während dem kochen und bringe das
unglück leitet
er hat wirklich talent
danke er schließt sie besser als ich
wir arbeiten gut zusammen
es gibt keine konkurrenz
eigentlich ist meine mutter die chefin
für das nachtessen
während des kochens streit mir nicht
dass ford die erinnert an das großes
ereignis vor vier jahren
unsere zivil hochzeit
[Musik]
in china muss man mit fingerabdruck
bestätigen
wie bei einem vertrag
unsere verlobung war wunderbar
ich habe natürlich alles mit meiner
mutter in der schweiz besprochen und
dann dachte ich jetzt ist es perfekt ich
muss es tun
ich ging also zum strand
zum glück war fast leer
ein unendlicher strand
mit einem arzt schrieb ich in den sand
willst du mich heiraten willst
[Musik]
du mich heiraten
mit einem herz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber etwas hat gefehlt
eine verlobung
ich war so aufgeregt und habe alles
gegeben aber
ich habe alles richtig gemacht und du
hast ja gesagt
elisabeth handschellen und matthias
hautsch ashburton
traditioneller chinesischer hochzieht
[Musik]
was drauf vorhand
trinken und beide ski
clubs gezahlt und das ist mir noch nie
passiert in grau
und
so hast du mich kraft
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
im kulturzentrum ist die beta für
konzerte und events zuständig und jede
freie minute machte selber musik
[Musik]
24 manage hotel ins rechte rand hatte
vielfach stellten sie wird das alte
problem gelöst werden auch die u mag
nehme
wir sind menschen und machen fehler in
einem hotel muss man mit allem rechnen
so etwas kann passieren
das macht mir nichts aus
sagt wird wie er damals
bargeldlos über handy rief er überwies
dem handwerk sei sie gerade mal 1
franken 20
kilo ries
[Musik]
der schlagzeuger wie sein vater
sei mit dem levin machte videos für den
youtube kanal
[Musik]
und wir sind unterwegs zumba klub suchen
wo sich die fia und die beta von
dies bedeutet frauen bezahlen keinen
eintritt
ich kam rein
ich war hier und du hast dich zu mir
gedreht
du hast mich angelacht ich kam zu dir
dann haben wir getanzt
so hat alles angefangen vor 20 jahren 17
jahren
aber dieser boden war nicht da
wir sind wie
magnete die einander anziehen
[Musik]
die beiden nägel gemacht
das touristenvisum beate reich
wie zwischen abgelehnt
und
[Musik]
so stets
vorbereitet so der sohn ist wieso noch
unter fünf metern in der schweiz ja dann
[Musik]
in der nächsten folgt vor hin und weg
der matthias und sind gerade job in
einer schweizer firma
was ist das problem
noch viele jahre macht wenn die
chinesische kritik kulturmühle
alle events sichtbare oder
andere personen formen heute manager
gesicht rechner und widersprechen
kulturelle unterschiede altes thema
tradition gibt aber auch stoff für
konflikte
sie ist meine mutter in unserer kultur
lassen wir die eltern nicht alleine
regiert dann endlich wieder ihre
düsteren die daumen
[Musik]
freudig überschattet wurde
hausherr
die familie auf dem land sind es
einfache verhältnis aber gestört sie das
nie
[Musik]
aktuell
42 ländern
das ist hin und weg
[Musik]
hin und her ich präsentiert wurde von dr